our international affairs editor dominic
wackhorn has this report and uh just to
warn you that it contains distressing
images
in retreats russian forces have revealed
a grisly trail of evidence of war crimes
the world's response has been swift and
unanimous this guy is brutal and what's
happening in bucca is outrageous and
everyone's seen it i think it is a war
crime we will not rest until these
criminals have been brought to justice
it's clear that there is clear evidence
of war crimes it was the russian army
that was in butcher international
justice must prevail
across ukraine russians have been
accused of targeting civilians and their
property a clear war crime but other
atrocities too
in butcher there's at least one mass
grave with civilian bodies elsewhere
civilians have been tied up and executed
across the kiev region say human rights
watch there were multiple rapes summary
executions the murder of women and
children and looting
there's been systematic and deliberate
destruction of civilian property
authorities in chernahev say 70 percent
of the city has been destroyed
drone footage suggests that barely a
building's been untouched by the bombing
and shelling of mariupol
there's no one single outrage more a
pattern of deliberate destruction of
civilian infrastructure and the massacre
and terrorization of hundreds if not
thousands of civilians since yugoslavia
and rwanda international prosecutors
have become better at identifying
suspects and prosecuting them ukrainians
have begun compiling evidence already to
hand to prosecutors from the
international criminal court
ukrainian human rights experts say the
list of russian suspects will be long
from president putin down
at the practice shows of the icc and uh
international criminal
tributary guns for rwanda and from
yugoslavia it doesn't matter if the
person is was a president or general or
the person was officer sergeant or
soldier it it matters what crimes were
committed
ukraine may be a victim of war crimes
but it's also a place of authority on
the laws surrounding them in particular
two legal scholars from this city lev
who practically invented the concepts of
genocide and crimes against humanity in
international law
work pioneered by ukrainian lawyers at
the nuremberg nazi trials in the
aftermath of world war ii
now tragically relevant again to the
people of ukraine
dominic waghorn sky news la viv